thank you for joining us here at i/o
today hello to everyone on the
livestream as well my name is Rob I'm an
engineering lead on the Android things
team and I'm joined today by chica who
is a product manager on our team this is
a lenovo smart display built using
android things you can think of it as a
visual google assistant or like a smart
speaker with the display you probably
heard in the keynote already or maybe in
Vince's talk earlier today that these
devices and others from JBL and LG will
be available on store shelves starting
this July just a couple of months from
now today we're gonna tell you the story
of how we built these devices from
prototype up to the production devices
that will be available in a few months
before joining the Android things team I
spent most of my career writing software
that ran on other people's devices
probably like many of you but building a
new piece of hardware at scale is
different from the kind of work I had
done before and it came with a lot of
new challenges and today we're gonna
tell you about some of them our hope is
that you leave this talk with a better
idea of what it's like to build consumer
hardware at scale and how Android things
makes it easier than it's ever been so
not that scary once you know what to
expect so I hope that our story of
prototypes of production can help you
build the device of your own if you are
a software developer thinking about
building consumer devices here are a few
things you probably care about first you
want to build your product features
without having to worry about the
underlying platform you also want to be
able to swap out underlying hardware
seamlessly without affecting your
application layer as the technology or
product needs evolve over time
you obviously want your devices to be
secure I think it's obvious why security
is increasingly an essential requirement
for smart devices they've all the keys
to our homes and our personal
information what's probably less obvious
is why it's hard to provide this kind of
security it's incredibly expensive to
harden products out of the gate and to
keep them updated over time meanwhile
there's immense cost pressure from end
customers and it's hard to amortized
cause without large volume
we know this at Google since we've been
doing this for many products coming back
to you finally if you're building a
consumer device you'd want to manage
release and update channels over time
Android things was designed with all of
these needs in mind we provide turnkey
Hardware in the form of pre certified
system on modules or what we call as
Psalms the psalm includes the CPU Wi-Fi
bluetooth memory and other critical
hardware components think of this as a
small computing platform that you can
use to build a variety of IOT devices we
bring up the operating system on new
Psalms tested and certified suitability
for production devices so that you don't
have to do any of this later on in the
talk we'll give you an inside look into
some of this work that Google handles
for you you provide the application code
and wire up the peripherals and Google
takes care of the rest what you see here
are smart displays from Lenovo LG and
JBL as Rob mentioned they are built
using Android things in fact if you look
under the hood all three products have
the same song which is pretty cool these
devices have far-field microphones that
can hear you from the other side of the
room and built-in speakers that can
answer back across the room just like a
smart speaker but now we also have a
touchscreen which makes it possible to
see visual results this is quite cool if
the result happens to be a list of
restaurant nearby x' or a map showing
you your commute conditions we announced
this earlier this year at CES and we're
very proud of the reception we received
let's dive a little deeper and see how
we built ease about a year back we at
Google were wondering if we could build
a visual Google assistant this would
enable deep integration with other
Google services such as YouTube photos
maps and so on building a consumer
device though is typically a long
process but for a fast evolving space
like smart home devices time to market
is extremely important we wanted
turnaround time and this is exactly
where Android things shines our goal is
to make it possible for software
developers like you to build consumer
devices at scale but that's a hard thing
to get right in a vacuum it takes
real-world experience in building and
shipping a lot of devices to know that
you've really done it this project would
give us the perfect opportunity to do
that in this case our customers were
software developers from other internal
teams at Google such as the Google
assistant team for Smart displays while
they took the lead on building
application software we hydrated on the
platform as a result we were able to get
these from prototype to production
superfast and we now have a stronger
platform for you to build on we started
by building some proof-of-concept
hardware for smart displays our goal was
to learn from that and to use the device
to kick off broader discussions across
the company so we took a few weeks and
some spare parts and built this this is
our first proof of concept hardware this
is running on some hardware that we had
used previously to deliver an Android
things powered smart speaker I built
this case with my son cost me about two
pokemon cards he still wonders when he's
gonna get his brick back bricks back
though this device doesn't have all of
the hardware that ships on the final
devices for example it's missing a
camera it doesn't have the volume
up/down buttons or mute of any sort but
that wasn't the point of this device for
this one what we were trying to do is
show just the basics of what we thought
we could achieve on the with the smart
display product to get some conversation
started the mic on this one in
particular was kind of tricky to use it
wasn't meant for this kind of use case
you needed a quiet room and you had to
stand in just the right sweet spot but
with a little bit of practice it was
possible to pull off a pretty convincing
demo with it on top of the Android
things platform and the smart speaker
code that we already had we built a
small Android application to drive the
display and show off some of the key use
cases we thought were going to be
important for this kind of device one of
the first things we did with the
displays to transcribe your query as you
spoke it it was a basic proof that
speech recognition pipeline was up and
running properly and it looked pretty
cool in a demo next up we added some
support for rudimentary what we call a
knowledge card that'll show a brief
snippet of text and a photo along with
answers to certain questions
this device couldn't play video yet
because it wasn't it didn't have the
hardware required for that but it could
stream music already just like a smart
speaker so we added title track display
and immediate transport controls like
pause and skip and then finally we took
a rough cut at the ambient screen which
is what the device does when it's not
doing anything else it showed a photo
slideshow and a weather forecast so like
I said just kind of a basic set of
functionality that we could use to show
people what we thought we could build
out of this it only took about two weeks
and a small team of people to get this
working but the result was actually
surprisingly close to the architecture
of the final products that are shipping
in a few months the changes between what
we built here and what we're shipping
are basically incremental changes
fundamentally what we built and what
we're shipping involves the smart
display application at the top of the
stack running on top of Android things
on top of a certified what we call a
some Android things brings the hardware
support the security the application
framework and the update mechanism while
the smart display application brings all
of the Google assistant integration and
the visuals for the device don't get me
wrong there was definitely a lot of work
to do between here and what we're
shipping this summer but as I said the
fundamental architecture is the same and
it was a matter of incrementally
building out the feature set from here
we practiced the demo routine with this
device and set up meetings across Google
over the next few weeks
people got a kick out of the brick case
that we built and we had a lot of great
discussions and some debate about
product features we should support about
Android things and about what we should
do next over all the demos went really
well and we got the buy-in that we
needed from key stakeholders across
Google to move on to the next step
with this project now that this was
going to be real we kicked off a few
steps in parallel to scale up our
efforts first our business development
team started discussion discussions with
potential alien partners in this case an
OEM or an original equipment
manufacturer refers to a company that
will build and sell the device they come
up with the industrial design and the
physical look and feel of the product
they also pick parts like the display
camera microphone and other audio
components if you were to build a device
on Android things you'll be the one
responsible for case design and
component selection in place of this
step you might find an industrial design
work firm to work with or a factory to
and a factory to build your product a
lot of details here will handle buyer om
partners and we are not going to cover
them today in parallel we started
finalizing the hardware requirements for
the product the proof-of-concept device
used a psalm that we had used to build
smart speakers but you can build
anything else from it that has similar
requirements as well for my displays
though we needed something more powerful
to support use cases such as video
playback fortunately we had some some
options in a roadmap that we started
evaluating finally in parallel to the
OEM selection and some selection we got
started on the application software
Google had already built out the
assistant back-end and client software
for smart speakers but turning a smart
speaker into a smart display isn't just
a matter of plugging in a touch panel
there's a lot of new work around the
home screen the video playback
experience the maps and photos
integration and essentially all the
other visual features that we were
trying to build with us turning the
application software from a humble
proof-of-concept device into a
production device was going to take a
lot of time most of the software work
was responsibility of developers outside
our team and they needed to get started
right away these engineers who are
software developers like many of you
don't want to have to think about the
underlying platform or the hardware but
because we are building this on Android
things they don't need to like we
mentioned earlier we can decouple the to
the application engineers work on top of
the android framework just like any
Android developer would their
application can run on any hardware with
Android things support so at this point
in the project
it's July of last year we're about a
month and a half into the work we've got
our proof of concept hardware we've got
some business development work underway
we've got the hardware selection
underway and we're nearly ready to get
started on the application software
development in earnest but in order to
really kickstart development we need to
get some actual hardware into the hands
of engineers and product managers and
other folks at Google who are going to
actually build this out but as we said
before the hardware that we used in that
proof-of-concept device was just a
little too slow to use for more than
just a demo so we looked through the
Psalms that we had in our pipeline and
found one that met the requirements for
this category of devices and it happened
to also be very easy to buy in quantity
over the Internet and we had Android
things already kind of running pretty
well on it so we decided to use this as
the basis for some provisional hardware
that we would build to unblock the
application engineers so that they could
get started on that on their job well we
finished out the hardware bring up we
knew that we would swap this hardware
out later when it got closer to
production but that would didn't that
didn't worry us because as we've said
we're building on Android things and
that gives you the isolation from the
hardware that you need to be able to do
that
the second problem ly we had though with
the provisional hardware was that it was
a development board kit similar to the
imx7 kits that were giving out here at
i/o which means that it had a display
and a camera connected to the baseboard
through flat flex ribbon cables you can
obviously work like this but it's a
little difficult to manage if you have
more than one on your desk for example
and we wanted to give these out to a lot
of Googlers for the first few weeks we
literally held the thing together that
are at our desks with cardboard and
rubber bands but that wasn't gonna scale
to the quantity that we wanted to
deliver for that we needed a more solid
enclosure to keep everything in one spot
and by the way if you do complete the
scavenger hunt here at i/o and you get
an imx7 kit make sure to keep the
packaging it turns into a handy stand so
you don't have to build one yourself so
this is the enclosure we came up with
for our first provisional hardware
honestly Android things didn't really
help or hurt either way in the building
of this case but I had a lot of fun
making it and I learned
in the progress in the process so I hope
you don't mind if I get gout for a few
minutes and tell you a little bit more
about this design and how we built it it
looks pretty plain from the front the
point is that it's just enough to keep
the hardware together and give you a
rough sense of the form factor that we
had in mind there is a camera module at
the top some microphones that we had
manufactured locally here in Mountain
View in the middle of the top and of
course the big touchscreen in the front
here's a quick view of the back the
somme and the carrier board are mounted
in the back of this big piece of wood
that I called the bezel here just like
most of the rest of the hardware you can
get to most of the ports easily from the
top and there's a little access for the
reset button on the side which is very
important when prototyping I want to
point out here though that pretty much
none of these components match the final
hardware obviously as we've said the
psalm is different so is the camera so
are the mics so is the display but again
not an issue because we're building
Android apps on this and they don't
really care so much about the specific
hardware underneath
building this prototype was my favorite
part of the project because at the time
the deadlines were far enough away so
that they don't make that crushing sound
they do when they get a little closer
and we were still a small team that
needed to be scrappy and pretty
resourceful so I literally built this
case in my garage over a few weeks and
the best part of that is that I got to
buy a new tool not just any tool but a
60 watt laser cutter which of course I
got off the internet
I literally learned how to use a laser
cutter for this project I ate it on the
design in my garage over the course of a
few weekends it was my first time using
any kind of 3d modeling package to do
this kind of design my first time ever
using a laser cutter and I basically
learned by watching videos online and
the point here is that if this is the
kind of thing you like yes you can do it
too and you'll probably have a lot of
fun doing it the material that I tried
first was this birch plywood it's about
three millimeters thick you can get it
in quantity from the net very easily to
day shipping in stacks of 25 or 60 if
you go for the bigger if you go for the
batch of 60 it's maybe a dollar and a
half a sheet or less so it's pretty cost
effective when I first tried building
this out I wasn't very efficient with my
material use it would take maybe two or
three sheets of plywood to build enough
parts
case but eventually you want to get a
little more optimized waste a little
less material and as you see here I
managed to fit the whole case in a
single 12-inch square sheet of plywood I
did have to fit one of the sides inside
of the bezel to make that work it was a
lot of fun to kind of it was a big
challenge to figure out how to get this
all into one sheet of plywood a lot of
fun to overcome that but laser cutters
only cut in 2d which meant it's a little
hard to work a fastener like a screw
into the into the design so this one is
all friction fit I came up with a tab
and slot design where you could put it
together by hand and it would stay
together pretty securely and the best
part of that was that it was actually
real easy to service in the field if a
connector comes loose or you need to
change a jumper you can snap the thing
apart with your hands you don't need to
find a screwdriver you fix it you put it
back together and you're good to go we
tried a few variations in other
materials such as the acrylic you see
here I think it looks much better than
the wood obviously this semi-transparent
red is really cool but what we found is
that in acrylic the thickness for us at
least the material we had the thickness
varied too much across color and even
within color so that when we put some of
the cases together they just fall apart
on a desk or they'd fit together so
tightly that the acrylic would snap at
the weak points which turned out to be
the 90 degree cuts from the material so
we decided to go with the wood after all
because it was going to be more robust
for us I cut about a dozen enough parts
to make about a dozen in these cases we
brought them into the office had some
people assemble them so that we could
try out the design we iterated on it a
bit eventually settled on a final design
and sent it off to an internal shop at
Google with a laser cutter that can cut
these in bulk if you happen to work for
a company that doesn't have a laser
cutter shop not a big deal you can find
plenty of places on the internet where
you can upload your CAD files they'll
cut them and send them back to you if
you've never worked with a laser cutter
before though I recommend you try one
out first before you send it off and
commit to a bulk order and get a feel
for what works and doesn't work in this
kind of design but again the moral for
this part of the story is that you can
build an enclosure - and laser cutters
are cool so you should try one out now
one more thing before we move on though
I mentioned we wanted to build
a lot of these we built 75 in the first
batch to spread around Google and we
thought that was going to be more than
enough but they were so popular that we
built another 75 and even that frankly
we could have used a bit more so once
you have this this many devices and
honestly once you have more than say one
or two you want a way to disambiguate
them to tell which ones which because at
some point someone will have a problem
they'll say hey man can you look at this
device and you'll say sure I'm busy
right now drop it off at my desk and
maybe they'll put it next to one that
looks just like it while you're away and
then you end up looking at the scorch
marks on the case to figure out which is
which so think ahead give each device a
serial number keep track of it in the
spreadsheet somewhere so you know how
much inventory you have left to give out
or who's got what or maybe what the
history of individual devices are so we
now have the hardware prototype to hold
over an application developers for a
short term in parallel we were working
on finalizing the salm force might
displace we evaluate certain options in
our roadmaps and kick-started another
series of discussions only this time it
was with the SOC vendors we eventually
selected a Qualcomm Psalm called as the
sta 6:24 for the lenovo LG and JBL
devices that are launching this year
paavana saz an eight-core a 53 with an
Adreno 5:06 GPO that supports display
and camera it's plenty capable of
driving a smart display and of course a
bunch of other potential devices that
you may want to build as well on the STS
X 24 Google will offer free stability
fixes and security patches for three
years with options for extended support
to give you a more concrete idea of the
hardware we are talking about here
here's a photo of the top of the somme
you can see the SOC the Wi-Fi Bluetooth
module the memory all mounted on a
discreet board here's the underside of
the somme the main thing going on here
are those three high-density connectors
with 100 pins each these pens make up
the Psalms interface to the outside
world here's a little deeper dive into
the psalm spin out interface the Pens
carry power GPIO lines and a wide
variety of peripheral bus
in and out of the song Wow looks a
little overwhelming doesn't it however
you wouldn't need to worry about
designing this if you if you were using
Android things to build your devices pen
assignment has been standardized along
with the rest of the psalm so that the
underlying platform know what the
expectations are in some cases you'll
also have the option of laying out the
psalm circuit flight onto your board
exactly as specified according to this
interface however it's much faster and
easier to just build a carrier board
that the psalm what you'll can plug into
so if you get one of our development
Psalms it'll come with a carrier board
that has some common i/o pins broken out
onto standard size header so that you
don't need to deal with any of these
high density connectors but when you do
build build a device for real for mass
production you'll likely want to spin
your own carrier board that connects to
whatever hardware you need for your
device for smart displays we came up
with a reference carrier board that we
asked our OEMs to follow you can see in
the slide here that in the middle we
have the psalm which again is the CPU
the Wi-Fi and other important parts and
the peripherals are connected around the
outside we standardized on button and
sensor connections in this reference
design specifying which GPIO s they
should connect into for example to
simplify our work on the software side
because we're working with three om
simultaneously we wanted to avoid as
much as we could
unnecessary customizations across OMS so
everybody for example plug their volume
up into the same GPIO on the some one
other thing we specified in the
reference design here is that the
microphone mute circuit should be
external to the some and implemented in
hardware so that when you mute these
devices the mics are electrically
physically disconnected from the sum so
that even in the face of some sort of
successful software exploit in the
future there's no way to unmute the
device and software similarly we
specified as part of the reference
design that the camera the camera mute
should physically cover the lens of the
camera so that there's no way to unmute
the camera so to speak in soft
we did leave some room for OEM
customization for example they could
select their own microphones they could
build their own audio output stages and
they had some leeway on display choice
as well this is the next revision of our
development kit this is what came after
the wooden kits that I showed earlier
this one is built according to the
reference design and it's using a lot of
the production components that we have
in real devices this time around the
entire front assembly was put together
by an outside firm and we didn't have to
do any of that this case happened to be
in acrylic as you can see used friction
fit gromek grommets to connect the
standoffs to the back these sometimes
came loose if you over tighten them but
you could fix it with a little bit of
superglue if you had to from the front
what we have here is the exact same
touch panel camera and microphones used
in some of our production devices we
added this acrylic back at Google which
held the speaker in place and really
just gave the front something to lean up
against so that it was at a similar
angle to what we were expecting for the
production devices inside these are
essentially the Qualcomm SDA 6to4 some
plugged into a carrier board that
matches the reference design this is
actually one of the earlier versions
which we called the EFI p1 and in these
versions the amplifier and the display
interface were on daughter cards that
plugged into the carrier board but on
later revisions we had it all flattened
down on to a single carrier board we
completed these kits in the beginning of
December of last year if you're not
aware of CES is July sorry June January
January 9th so he basically had just
just a month to go before the big show
where we were going to show off these
devices at CES so it was a little
nerve-wracking especially in those weeks
leading up to the delivery of these
devices where the CES was getting closer
and closer but in fact the application
engineers had gotten off to a great
start with the wooden devices and we
sorted out the platform bring up on the
Android things side relatively quickly
so it's really kind of amazing that one
month before this huge demo at CES we
were able to completely swap out the
hardware
we moved the entire development team
platform and application engineers from
those wooden prototypes over to devices
running on a completely different SOC
without a hitch and this is because
thanks to Android things a smart display
application is totally independent of
the platform you can see how this was
useful to us because we had this kind of
provisional situation where we needed to
bring up temporary Hardware before the
real stuff was ready but this can be
really useful in production devices as
well you may ship this year with a
certain profile a certain piece of
hardware that you need and then next
year maybe you want to cost it down or
you may want to add new features and
switch to a more powerful piece of
hardware and because of this you can
easily reuse the application software
across a wide variety of hardware
platforms so around the same time as our
reference hardware was being completed
our OEM partners Lenovo JBL and LG were
busy building out their own devices
based on the reference design that we
showed before those that I did Google
even closer to CES we got them with just
about two to three weeks to spare but
again the transition was relatively
smooth we hit a few bumps for example on
one of our devices the camera looked
green which we eventually traced to a
missing capacitor but essentially
nothing that we couldn't sort out on
time CES was a lot of work I remember
cursing whoever it is who should use it
so close to holidays this is a picture
of our war room that we set up a few
weeks before CES we spend a lot of time
here planning the demos adding features
and fixing last-minute bugs on the
device and on the backend servers that
make it work on the demos we plan to
show rich integration with other Google
services such as YouTube photos and maps
this is a picture of a little kids room
that we set up in Mountain View which
had nest cameras pointing at it and we
could check in on a little Android baby
all the way from Vegas our hard work and
careful planning paid off and the demos
pretty much worked like they were
supposed to we had some issues setting
up the venue and a few hardware glitches
but we brought backups expecting that to
happen the reception we got from the
press and users at CES was very
encouraging
when you are hard at work on something
in secret it's hard to gauge how the
outside world is going to react to it
getting this kind of positive feedback
was a great shot of motivation for the
team and helped further galvanize their
foot after CES it was time to get out of
the demo mindset and back to the work of
shipping at this point we were flushed
with hardware from our OEM partners and
the program was ramping up up up till
now we were handing out a single
software bill to all our developers but
now we needed to expand out fortunately
Android things makes this super easy
using what we call as channels our
developer console allows you to manage
release and update channels over time
you can get a lot more details and how
this works in a de minimis stop tomorrow
so for smart displays we establish
multiple channels for our internal user
segments depending on their needs for
example our developers have medium to
high risk tolerance and can replace
components as necessary we have a dev
channel for them we also have a cannery
for high risk tolerant developers where
we roll out daily bills of course we
have a different channel for a keyway or
testing teams so that we can give them
early access to bills that we want
tested at this point we also have
hundreds of Googlers who are testing out
smart displays and giving us feedback on
features these people need more stable
channels and they have lower risk
tolerance so we roll out stable weekly
bills for them with known good
functionality and we skip bills in case
their I shoes we are getting close to
the end of the talk but I want to cover
one more thing before wrapping up in
this day and age if you're shipping
software you never really need to be
completely done with it if you're
building a website or a mobile
application you can roll out bug fixes
whenever you will but when it comes to
hardware you only get one shot at it
once it's in the hands of the user
that's it there are some things that
even software cannot fix at that point
so you better get it right you also just
cannot keep the factory running
continuously though making small tweaks
here and there you need to purchase your
building materials in bulk and since
it's still early in the
says you're not going to be ready to buy
in mass production quantities also the
tooling and testing takes some time to
set up and change so this process
usually happens across a few bills that
are standard in the hardware development
lifecycle you can read up more about
those on internet but I'll cover it in
briefly today so we already talked about
the prototype phase the next phase is
the EVT or the engineering validation
test for this phase you're trying to
validate that you got your schematics
right you don't have any layout issues
and your components work with each other
the way they are supposed to if you are
still considering different design
options you can eye trait on them this
is a good and this is a good time to do
so this essentially represents the first
attempt at building your boards the way
they'll appear inside your final device
the enclosure is typically still not
final at this stage so you may want to
keep the board's hot-glued screwed or
taped just to keep them from flipping
around the next stage is the DVT or the
design validation test the purpose here
is to verify your production processes
and equipment to ensure that they are
meeting your final specifications the
devices we got for CES for what we
called as pre DVT they were soft tooled
which means that the molds used to cast
the plastics were made of a soft
material like silicon again you may want
to do a few bills here until you get to
a point where you know that there are no
fixes that would need a hardware spin
you ramp up quantities that you get more
confidence and eventually you want to
get to a run with hot tool plastics the
PV T or the production validation test
is typically the last build that
transitions into mass production
hopefully by now you've logged in the
final software that you will be flashing
in on these devices at this point you
are also hoping that your factory is
pretty much running on autopilot without
any manual intervention finally your
product is ready to go to mass
production which means it's ready to be
on shelf at this stage you're ramping up
production and focusing on making
process improvements to improve the hint
you obviously want to continue testing
it for the next few months though as
well as established some sort of
reliability testing
so there that's how we build smart
displays from prototype to production to
reiterate having Android things as the
underlying platform helped us in every
step of the way first thanks to the
android framework our software
developers could focus on building
application features without having to
worry about the underlying platform our
system on module or swarm solutions
allowed them to swap out underlying
hardware seamlessly as we moved from one
prototype kit to the other without
affecting that layer and yes while we
needed it to do a lot of work to bring
up the Psalms first my displays you
don't need to do any of this the smart
display song will be ready for your use
soon I'll update and device management
features allowed for fast iterations and
easy maintenance of multiple devices on
the field and finally our security
features mean that our OEM partners and
users don't have to worry about the
security of these devices so we have a
lot more to show you at i/o I'll come
and see us at the Android things sandbox
dome which you can see on the left side
of the map here the entire dome is
filled with Android things demos and
it's open after hours as well you can
see how we leverage machine learning
firebase and the cloud platform and you
can also have an up close look at the
prototypes and the devices that we
talked about here today by the way
you'll notice Android things powered
devices outside of the sandbox dome as
well there's survey boxes all around i/o
that are built on top of Android things
and a large human size robot roaming
around ready to take a selfie with you
so you can come to our code labs as well
showing sort of in the middle area of
this map we have code labs showing how
to work with tensorflow how to work with
cloud IOT and how we made the survey
boxes that are around i/o and even more
there are seven more sessions on Android
things coming up today and tomorrow they
go even deeper into some of these topics
finally have some fun at i/o we have a
scavenger hunt going on shown at the
link here gqo / io search I won't give
away too much but you'll run into some
machine learning enhanced flowers which
are pretty cool and if you solve all the
puzzles and make it to the end then
you'll get a piece of developer hardware
to take home for yourself with that I'd
like to
you invite you to go build some hardware
and I hope that we're leaving you with
some new confidence that you too can
build the device with Android things go
to the link mentioned here to get
started today thank you
[Music]